luke and tom with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and we're exploring
world war ii battlefields and catching
enormous fish
welcome
to onalaska
i promised tom that if he got his grades
up i would take him on a really awesome
father-son adventure and he said he
wanted to do something with world war ii
history and halibut fishing and there's
only a handful of places in the world
where you can do that and that's dutch
harbor alaska
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we can go anywhere even if there's
nothing there i don't really care
[Music]
and then
well dutch harbor's famous for a couple
things including being the home of a
number of reality tv shows
[Music]
but also it was the site of a major
battle in world war ii and it's also
where the biggest halibut in the world
was caught over 400 pounds
and we're gonna go fishing for halibut
while we're here you excited for that
tom yeah it's gorgeous
hey so people can give us a ride here
good yeah nickels this is my boy tom
pleasure hey thank you you have a good
day
all those guys are from the coast guard
and they uh watch our videos so that was
awesome
yeah look at this
all right tom should we go explore a
little bit yes
gonna walk over to the local grocery
store here alaska ship supplies
if you're going out fishing your brand
new deckhand is where you come and get a
lot of your gear a lot of people from
russia asia and polynesia that work here
bitter melon leaves palm heart we've got
banana sauce this stuff is amazing on
hot dogs
okay we need to get snacks
all right
ube cake
they got mogu okay put that in
i love dutch harbor
oh these are for cod traps
you tommy you think we got enough junk
food for tomorrow yes there are eagles
all over look there's a juvenile bald
eagle right up there look at the size of
those aren't those huge
at the beginning of world war ii dutch
harbor was one of only three military
bases in alaska and if you look at a map
you'll figure out why it's really close
to japan and
russia can see artifacts from world war
ii all over the place check it out it's
a pill box
is that cool yeah you imagine fighting
in
like bullet here it looks like bullet
holes doesn't it
look at this tom
that is a buckle yeah probably for my
shoulders uniform or something you know
what this is
tell me what that is that's like a 50
caliber bullet casing tommy you want
that yes
i wonder if it's like a an artillery
shell is this pretty cool
yes he's having way too much fun
you found a jeep it's the axle like a
truck
see this is like an alternator or a
generator
yeah look at this
yeah
look there's all sorts of little bits
and bolts and oh see here's another
buckle oh another one there's buckles
everywhere near the beginning of world
war ii there was a major battle between
the japanese and the americans here at
dutch harbor and there's a bunch of
historic stuff there's an underground
hospital and there's a bunker and
there's a lot of stuff around town that
we're gonna check out
we're gonna be here for like three days
and i'm getting kind of hungry tom let's
go get some dinner
that's a crane yeah there's an engine
block oh yeah there's some big gears or
something over there
yeah it is
a question
one right there and one right there and
there's one over there
oh look at this tom you can look down
the coast there's another bunker there's
another bunker there's another bunker
you hungry bud yeah food
are you full buddy yeah i'm full
yeah there's a machine gun bunker in the
hotel parking lot i think this is
happening already
[Music]
yeah that was all covered in lupine this
one
yeah oh there's the entrance
all right you can just go
oh
well this has been a lovely day but it
is getting late and we got to get up
early to go fishing so shall we go to
bed yes all right i'll see you guys in
the morning
[Music]
oh we found a ride here hop on in bud
yeah so you're trying to sort of get
through
whatever you see there that was like hi
danny
we're here with keeping it real fishing
charters and me and tommy to go out for
some halibut and we got captain ben here
who's gonna put us on some fish and we
got
deckhand danny here who's gonna help us
get it done
i'm excited this is my first time
fishing for halibut in the bering sea so
the world war ii bunker right up there
in the rock
how deep is it here oh like it's like
100 to 200 depending where we are geez
that's like shallow water halibut
fishing
that's the jig we're using yeah we're
just popping just bouncing because we're
not fishing with enormous baits in
weight we don't need those huge
broomstick rods this is going to be fun
to find a halibut on you got one tub
already yes where you got we got bait
oh
sculpin
but we used to call these irish lords
they have spines all over look at that
spines there spines there
so i got a little piece of sculpin or
irish lord on there
give that a go
it's up
what are you really
yeah go for it stop fighting
oh my goodness
oh look at that oh that is a beautiful
cod
you got it
oh job look at that
all right we're gonna keep him
a beautiful cod
let that one go did you see the size of
that thing you're gonna see more of that
job we've had lures in the water for
less than two minutes and we've already
had four fish on tom's already got
another one over there
look at this i think i already have one
i think it was hit before i even tied my
lineup
[Music]
you got one
a salmon shark just bit him in half yeah
i saw a salmon shark bit your fish in
half
that's a new one tommy's fish was bitten
half by a salmon shark it's the closest
relative of the great white they get up
to like 18 feet long every once in a
while they'll actually catch and land
them if we get one of those it's going
to be awesome
this is just insane action guys we
haven't been doing this five minutes and
it's just cod every five seconds two
seconds
ah
i'm catching all the babies
now i am working hard today i'm sitting
here trying to jig reeling my fish and
film tommy and he is just
getting them hand over fist another one
tom you are out fidget every one of your
fish is bigger than every one of mine
there we go
[Music]
is this everything you hope for
yeah
that technically hard food the harpoon
has a little dart that sticks in before
i even had a chance to do my first jig
nice
that's about my size oh that's the
biggest compliment you could have given
me tom
oh look at that guys we haven't been
doing this 30 minutes i've already lost
count of how many of these we've hooked
we adjusted the boat a little bit got a
little bit different drift here
see if we can't pick up some halibut
oh something hit back out you just hit
this one oh
oh it's not even that big
i was here grunting a lot
[Music]
i guess we could blow that one we're
gonna catch a lot of them aren't we
yeah there's some parasites oh yeah he's
got these little blood sucking parasites
and skills ben's got one of these daiwa
electric reels for tommy he's getting
tuckered out reeling in all these
massive cod one after another long eight
hours
we got eight hours of this you gotta
keep your arms fresh
[Music]
enormous cod
help
you got you got a nice one
yeah 12
11.
all right tom reel him in
oh there we go
that is the smallest cod tom has caught
all day
see you later all right we're gonna move
all right another stellar drift we're
just gonna reposition the boat drift
some more this is awesome guys you're
getting to see world war ii history
you're reeling in cod after cod you're
eating junk food
everything is every kid's dream
this is amazing just ripping in one
after another of these 10 to 20 pound
cod and knowing that any minute we can
catch a halibut up to 400 pounds or a
salmon shark that weighs like who knows
how many hundreds
the cod are so plentiful here there's no
size restrictions and there's no bag
limit you can literally catch them till
the boat starts to sink
we fished for a total of three minutes
with only one cod so this is what they
call a terrible spot here in dutch
harbor apparently yeah so
there's no point
better wet suit
the egg looks like nobody outside
that's another cod
a little black bass
nice black bass these are definitely a
good eating fish we're going to try
another little spot
[Music]
it's bigger than yours of course that is
a chunky black bass tom
oh hey tom
i think mine's a little bigger let's put
them up beside each other let's see
oh
look at that black bass
that is a
porker
is in there
look what tommy caught it's a sea star
and look at the mouth see
yeah why why does it grab on to you
hey people speaking at home that's cool
another god but yeah let's see what do
you got in your mouth i guess
yeah he just puked up a hairy hair sorry
but i'm gonna put that back in there
that was yours oh yeah that's why you
grab them by the eyes
oh they got chompers i forgot about that
i've been on a lot of salt water trips
here in alaska and any other trip i
would have been thrilled over the moon
for a cod that big and that's less like
a like a small average here this is
crazy
i don't know why
you know i play it like it's a salmon
shark and then you know
the little guy
oh
bob's got a little helmet okay ready so
just hold your pole yeah we'll be
letting this little guy go yeah look at
his dad
[ __ ] tommy first halibut
they are such a violent fish when you
bring them on board that's why you have
to shoot the big ones
there's tom just going to town on his
like
15th or 20th fish
62.
oh
we're
good that's a nice one a little nicer
yeah you could probably let it go we'll
be catching a lot more i think
he's caught or putting such an awesome
bend in the rod i know if i catch a
decent halibut it's just gonna light me
up it's gonna be awesome
baby little baby hell of it and of
course
not as big as tommy's we got three fish
on at the same time
if i was in homer i'd be keeping this we
are not in homer
i know
oh they put up such a great fight
that's putting way more bend in the rod
than a salmon ever would
oh
tom that is a beef cod right there oh
it's pooping yeah
that is a big cod
oh look he bit my tail off
that is such a nice cod
[Applause]
look at that man they keep vandalizing
our lures
another nice con
just saying i know they're both lovely
god
fire sword
oh that is a nice cod
and my king sculpt in there i'll do that
[Music]
there you go nice eating size halibut
you got it
there you go
all right tom congratulations
all right that is a nice fish that's 18
pounds or so
40 of the halibut's body weight is just
in place so you get a lot of meat out of
it one hell of it
push them in here
[Applause]
crazy
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
it's nice bath
of course yours is bigger tom yours is
bigger okay
oh my goodness yeah they are yeah you
can see them right there
they're right here by the boat
we got these rock fish these black bass
are sitting here right under the boat
they're right on the surface we're gonna
we're gonna grab some of this light
tackle and try them you can keep a lot
of black look at that i can see i saw
him take it too much
so they should come up they'll start
jumping out of the water i just got one
hit right there under the boat
yeah they are oh there's another one
that is a nice fish look at the size of
this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
can you see him now
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
this is top water black bass fishing i
have never heard of anything that crazy
he put a black pass in my crotch now
daddy gets the fish
[Music]
oh we got double if you broke into bass
pro shop and started fishing their
aquarium you couldn't do better than
this
[Music]
[Music]
then this is insane is this normal for
you every day every go into the kelp and
catch them out of the water
normal day in dutch harbor
we were just trying to kill half an hour
basically
there is not a single boat in sight this
is amazing well the tides turn favorably
and so we're gonna go try a little
halibut spot
oh my arms are getting sore let's see
how tommy's doing
oh we got a man down
[Music]
you get a good nap tom
here with the last two yeah
that's a solid fish that is a solid yeah
oh my that is the same yeah i'm keeping
that all right okay hey hey get back
here
[Music]
you guys keep your guests sharp
all right look at this all right you got
it we got a double dog double trouble
i think mine's a little bigger tom oh
yeah i only got to buy a couple pounds
you like this waking up to reeling in
big halibut yeah
yeah good buddy
[Music]
[Music]
i felt large
well we got a triple going on here
look at this double cod action bigger
one than me that's a solid cod
that is a healthy car that feels like 20
pounds right there
move him in with a pile of flesh in
there
whoa got a good one
decent
60 or 70
oh my goodness
this is this is the biggest halibut i've
ever caught and ben was like um maybe
throw it back
[Music]
like those guys had good
well there we go we limited it out me
and tom both got two halibut wow what a
day we've got so much match we're gonna
get back to the dock flip a ton of fish
and uh there we go check out some world
war ii stuff and tomorrow
we're doing more efficient pretty
standard next pretty saturday night
not so standard
you get jeez
yeah stellar sea lions on the beach
there's dozens of them
wow
i don't even have a clue how many black
bass we kept
look at that man that is a lot of fish
and look at the size of these cod
man there's a jet
that is a big cod those hell of it are
awesome we're gonna get so much meat off
those halibut
those are nice gods
you peel the skin off it all the ones
come out
i boil them and it makes
french
oh
chunk of meat
you're just living the dream tom
living the dream
ever from there
and we never never make people delay
fish two of them just found it see that
down there's whales over there
thank you ben
see you in the morning
should we go see some world war ii stuff
yeah let's do it
all right guys first on our agenda is
we're gonna climb that mountain because
there's a big bunker on the end of it so
apparently it's called bunker hill
hey dad this is the place that you get
blisters i look at this bald eagle
feather it's so pretty here look at all
the wildflowers
[Music]
so
[Music]
you're climbing through the top
they would have pieces of bulletproof
metal that would slide around and cover
the holes
you want to go down
there oh yeah
i could shoot out over the entire harbor
look at that
this was our killer piece what is what
i'm sitting on
and then you
these um the plates that they would put
over the slots to keep the bullets from
coming in
he's just falling down here
if i get knocked down
[Music]
i think that's where the they put a gun
right there and they'd be able to shoot
anything that came this way
the ruins of an old building was here
yeah that's where they lived
ruins of another building right down
there
yeah this is where they'd put the big
artillery pieces and they could spin
them around to point them any direction
they wanted
oh they had another artillery piece down
there you can see the foundation
yeah i see these you'd fill these up
with dirt and you'd stack them around to
make sandbags for protection
look over here
fighting halibut and cod all day
and then hiking up this mountain and my
back and legs are screaming
yeah it is this was just sticking in the
ground
it was just right there seriously right
there that's crazy look at that tommy
just found a military shell casing on
the side of the road
oh look a dumpster eagle
yeah
oh
my gosh
i got some advil in me and we're sitting
here enjoying some roasted chicken here
in our hotel room and
having a good day aren't we yeah but
anyway i'm gonna put this camera down
and i'm gonna see you guys in the
morning
swell
away right guys we're heading out we're
doing it again
no those are whiskered aquits there we
go we just saw hundreds and hundreds of
whiskered oclets which if you're into
birding
it's kind of cool it's a bird that's
only found here in the aleutian and in
eastern russia look at this beautiful
weather here
yeah it's so hard to film this because
while i'm really in this one fish
there's been like three other fish
landed that i didn't film a lot of
things you guys aren't seeing
yeah it's probably like a it's like a
40. this is the first trip i've ever
been on where people even think about
sending back a 40 pounder
see you later bud
daddy you got a daddy size cod like a
small one like daddy catches yeah
yeah straight up flop it over
there you go you i think that's your
first fish you've ever gaffed buddy
got that arm warmed up
i got something no
no we can put it back
back
all right tom who do you got hear that
oh god get under it look at that that's
cool tommy congratulations
they're two firsts for me today first
time i've ever seen anyone throw back a
40 pound halibut and the first time i've
ever seen somebody move spots because
all they caught was a 40 pound halibut
it's too slow
really
yeah
oh black bass
well that's not how you eat it
barely hooked
and it just got off oh
we just thought it was like a normal cod
or something and we pulled it up and
there's a nice lean caught on there he
was just barely hooked and he popped off
right at the side of the boat lean
caught a really good eating now we would
not turn one of those down another nice
black bass
yes
there we go you got us over the top for
you
oh is the yellow eye the yellow eye
oh man
we're keeping that keeping those are
good those are really good eating fish
that is a nice yellow eye
yeah
what what the heck is that
[Music]
i'm not even getting to the bottom
they're just nailing it
reel up you probably have a face
of course i do
oh look at the swarm of them they're
underneath the ball they're buddy
clearly tommy
oh
the hell of it yeah i'll let him go
[Music]
oh
these electric reels are perfect for tom
because it's still a big battle for him
but he can hold the rod with both hands
that doesn't have to worry about reeling
they got a con
says it might be an octopus
yeah
got spines all over and like half their
body his mouth
all right guys we go try another spot
so this is
cod fish pate it's very kind of you
thank you daddy
i have never had cod liver before
it smells a little bit like smoked
salmon
definitely got a fishy kick to it
it's got that oily like fishy
flavor i have a very strict don't eat
anything danny gives you a rule
better be better than the seal oil you
made me
that's not bad at all just bad clams out
of a can
yeah i i need that
i actually ain't bad at all that's not
bad i'm like totally double dipping
danny's never i've never seen danny
drink a wider eat it piece of fruit
every little seeds
[Music]
those gods are just so thick
hold on i might have a
double helmet
[Music]
this might be the smallest cod of the
entire trip
just another double
ben what'd you say you buy like 2 000 of
these at a time for each season yeah
you've got this
yeah that's a good eating fish
are you the cod king tom
i have no clue how many dozens of these
tom has reeled up that he's he's an
expert
[Music]
feel a little bit better oh that's it i
feel bad oh
nice guy
[Music]
nice little triple going on here
there you go nice triple we have caught
so many doubles and triples
it's just insane
little baby jalapeno
[Music]
there you go
if we give him a push tom
there you go
[Music]
there you go
we've been hopping around fishing spots
a little bit but it's starting to get a
little rough so we're gonna head back to
the harbor
and uh we're gonna go look for some
whales
yeah
check it out there's a blow spout right
there there's a whale
right there see dead ahead right
we've seen so much wildlife on this trip
i might have to go back through all the
video footage and make a list of
everything we saw
[Music]
this is the wreck of the northwestern it
was bombed during the japanese attack on
dutch harbor they dragged it out here
and scuttled it the japanese attack on
dutch harbor was a big deal it was
actually an attempt to establish a
landing zone so the japanese could
attack the west coast because at that
time you couldn't fly across the pacific
on one tank of fuel
but they were unable to establish air
superiority during the two-day attack on
dutch arbor
and because of that they had to cancel
the landing invasion and instead they
went west to the islands of atu and
kishka and they took over those islands
and the japanese occupied those islands
for 18 months
and it took over 5 000 american
casualties and a year and a half to get
the japanese out of there
oh guys what an amazing trip we caught
an incredible amount of fish and i
didn't get to film
anywhere close to all of it but all
together i estimate we caught somewhere
between 1 000 to 1500 pounds of fish
and the crazy part is this is one of the
most affordable
sea trips you can do in the state of
alaska
[Music]
there's your fish the beauty
there we go
we were a lot more level-headed today
and released a lot more fish hey what
tom you're gonna be a killer deckhand
not too long
hell i can't believe you ate it you see
those spines are digested
and boom see that yeah
then the skin stays pull that and see
you just do the stuff we put on the
crackers yeah that's the liver right
there that's a raccoon i like that it
tastes like seaweed
it is light it's compact well ben thanks
for the ride and thanks for two amazing
days of fishing thank you guys for
coming out listen if you guys are ever
in dutch harbor alaska you need to go
with keeping it real fishing charters
they're amazing this is probably the
most affordable way to catch halibut and
cod and rockfish in the state of alaska
it's awesome fill your freezer for the
year and today
absolutely i'm gonna go ahead and put
their website in the video description
below so make sure to check that
[Music]
you want to go out some world war ii
stuff and go get some souvenirs for
mommy and the boys yes
it's good we could go to this just go to
this
see how you're doing on sleeves
and you like the green
all right we got souvenirs for all my
boys and rebecca
so this is the underground hospital here
in dutch harbor
yeah
yeah i see it
it's all boarded up
oh look at someone's tied ropes to climb
up inside it that's the hospital for the
military base
well tommy have you enjoyed seeing all
the world war ii stuff yes there's so
much we didn't get a chance to see
there's a museum for the history of the
aleutian islands the national park
service has a museum up on valley who
hill hey tommy you want to come back
again another time and see all this
stuff and do more fishing yeah
that food tastes good tomorrow
that hit the spot tom
yeah that's another bunker i didn't even
notice it's so buried there it is down
there
we just found another machine gun bucker
well guys it's late we got to get to bed
but this video is not over yet i'll see
you guys in the morning
that's a lot of strawberries buddy
oh my goodness
this is all of our fish guys in 50 pound
boxes just shy under 200 pounds that's a
lot of fish yeah we gotta throw a big
party a couple of them i didn't think it
was that much but it is i'm really glad
we let those halibut go now and uh by
the way happy birthday
[Music]
take a ride here on 200 pounds of frozen
halibut this is how we cruise with our
homies here in dutch harbor
just rolling up to the airport on 200
pounds of fish
all right guys we just checked in our
bags including our 200 pounds of fish
and if i remember correctly halibut is
about 25 a pound cod's about 14 15 a
pound so rough estimate that's about
four thousand dollars worth of fish we
just checked into the airlines
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Music]
each box is 50 pounds
there you go there's there's 50 pounds
all right we're gonna go donate some of
the fish to the native hospital you guys
ready yeah yeah we're at the alaska
native hospital here in anchorage and
we're gonna be donating a bunch of that
fish a lot of the native elders and
native people who spend their whole life
living off of traditional foods off in
the bush they come into anchorage for
treatment and then they can't get access
to their comfort food the food they're
used to eating and so people donate wild
meats and wild fish so they can have
something comfortable and familiar to
eat while they're here
and that's exactly what we're going to
do
oh good job we got one that's 50 pounds
and it's all vacuum sealed frozen and
flavored so thank you there we go here
get back in and get buckled in
all right guys it is a lovely day and
we've got some beautiful halibut tacos
getting fried up here
oh those are looking pretty good
[Music]
halibut tacos here
made some uh jalapeno cilantro sauce to
go with it
did you guys ever end up doing that tour
well i hope you guys have enjoyed this
video if you want to see more fishing
and adventure videos from the outdoor
boys youtube channel make sure to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
saturday morning and thanks for watching
we'll see you guys next saturday if you
like this video don't forget to check
out the outdoor boys youtube channel
where we have hundreds of videos just
like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
i thought you would think those were
super cute they do
and they're great